i put up on my instagram uh
that come pig photo from a sketch i did
years ago okay look at that eli roth
happy birthday to q
very fun uh i put that up
and i said today is my birthday i want
to thank my parents for all their
support this is what you created
enjoy it and my aunt
wrote a comment and the comment let's
not find it
and the comment was and my cousin sent
me the comment my con the comment was
the saddest part is that you have your
grandfather's name
and you don't care at all and you care
nothing about his legacy
very very nasty comment very very nasty
comment
and you know me i hate to bring
family drama on the show i hate that
you know i don't do it we can get this
down
i i really don't do it okay uh my aunt
kathleen
by the way okay uh
comes from me on instagram
brings up my grandfather and insults me
on the day of my birth
now let's get something straight you bum
[ __ ]
didn't you fake a drug overdose
didn't you fake a suicide attempt i
keenly remember
you faking that you overdosed on drugs
and you were taken to a hospital in an
ambulance
in front of your mother who had just
dealt with grandpa's death
what part of grandpa's legacy were you
honoring with that behavior
what part of it do you remember that i
remember you going to a hospital
and then having the entire family go
worried about you
not me but other people because i know
what you're up to you clown [ __ ]
they went to the hospital and said what
drugs is she on doctor
and the doctor goes there are no drugs
in her system
she literally pretended to be
unconscious
so then an ambulance went to the home
put her
in it and drove her to the hospital
scaring her mother half to death
grandpa's legacy okay
what part of grandpa's legacy were you
thinking about when you took his money
for law school
and then never practiced law and were
fired
multiple times by multiple law firms
all over long island because you're
mentally ill
forcing uh your father to
set up a pretend law office for you in
your
basement that you pretend to be a lawyer
in
you added a phone line to the house to
pretend
to be an attorney what part of the
legacy
is that what part of the legacy is
borrowing money
from your more successful brothers and
sisters
and not paying any of it back while you
sit around the house doing percocet and
drinking white wine
what part of the legacy is that are you
honoring his days as a carpenter
is that what you're honoring by sitting
around and getting junked up on the
couch
pretending to ot and by the way the life
you live
you don't even have to pretend okay you
can't even do that right
so i'm just wondering why you would
bring up my grandfather i have all the
respect in the world for a legendary
character
patriarch of an amazing family rose from
poverty did all these things
why come on my instagram and say
anything negative
and and bring up a guy who every day
with your life and your choices where is
his legacy in mind kathleen and i know
you watch this
okay in between reading q drops and
letting
fox news broil you're already viking an
adult brain
okay it's the wrong day kathleen i'm the
wrong one
you know that i blocked you on the
family uh i i got a new phone
to get out of the family [ __ ] group
text because you kept texting people
about
all the dishes they have to do when they
come to the family parties
[ __ ] no one's coming anymore no one
cares i don't want to be
near you you should be in a padded room
how my mother is in an asylum and you
have somehow escaped it
is beyond me and it's beyond everybody
you are a disgrace drug addict
potentially closeted lesbian you've
never moved out of the house
nobody respects you you are a pedophile
probably
you are gross around kids nobody wants
you [ __ ] taking baths with their
[ __ ] kids
you're a [ __ ] weirdo they gotta watch
you like [ __ ] epstein
so don't f keep my name out of your
mouth okay pedophile drug addict
this is the fake business mug
and the fake business mug uh is
is not on sale anymore oh it is for sale
until the 28th yeah
i just thought it was a bit rude how she
came from me brought up my grandfather
said something very nasty to me i mean
what part of my grandfather's legacy do
you honor by
not working this is a guy that worked
every day of his life
uh so you don't work you don't have a
family
you steal money you fake drug overdoses
you're a moral degenerate you you you
have no respect for people
you drive wedges in between people in
the family and you attack
successful people in the family my
grandfather did
none of those things he was a devoutly
religious
incredibly generous brilliant hard
worker
who raised an entire family you are the
exact opposite
of all of those things all of those
things
okay every one of them i blocked you
i got a new phone to get out of the
group chat because i didn't want to deal
with
your constant terrorism or updating me
like hey
uh little tom got his license who hey
who gives a [ __ ]
dummy get a job get a [ __ ] job
i have a job why don't you get a job
stop worrying about who got their
license nobody wants you neither family
you [ __ ] freak where's your man [ __ ]
where's your woman where's anything
what are you doing i mean let's get real
i mean this is a woman who does nothing
but but attack attack attack
and by the way [ __ ] my fam
and i like some of them but and then my
aunt goes like this
uh she goes like this she goes
she goes oh you know if i bump she's
told this to somebody else because if i
bumped into him
i'd really give him a piece of my mind
how are you gonna bump into me [ __ ] i
don't live in your kitchen
okay you've never left you've never left
home
i'm in malibu oh how am i gonna bump
into you
okay buying tampax at the local cvs
for your barren childless vagina how
would we ever bump heads together
keep my name out of your mouth
scumbag you're a degenerate
you're a moral digit this isn't even a
podcast anymore
i'm talking directly to you you are a
failure and a moral degenerate
okay come pig from a sketch a few years
ago on my chest
is a funny dumb joke you my friend
are a disgusting nightmare
that nobody wants to be around you're a
thief you've stolen people's money
haven't you kathleen you've stolen money
haven't you
you know you have where's the money
kathleen
did you take it you took all the money
didn't you
and then you go cry some people the
family be like you're being too hard on
her
[ __ ] you too hey [ __ ] you
too you think i give a [ __ ] about any of
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] i have a family okay
it's joe rogan and candace owens my
mother and father
give a [ __ ] about you [ __ ] clowns go
do a [ __ ] irish step dance i don't
give a [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is out of her [ __ ] my you
are
out of your mind just bringing my
grandfather my instagram trying to
trying to knock me like that
it's a shitty thing to do especially
from you
who's accomplished
zero in your entire [ __ ] life so
that's kind of how i wanted to start off
the show because i just and it's not the
whole show but i just want to
you know get it out in the open the way
that i feel about this woman
uh who's who just every opportunity she
she
tries to neg me and she does it on a
public forum
and i will do it now on a public forum
too so i apologize and i i would be
worried
that you'd sue me but you don't know how
to practice law
you're not a real lawyer are you because
you work from a basement
and you have pretend clients you set up
a care bear
you had from when you were [ __ ] nine
and you still have because you never
left your house
and you go hello mr carebear did you
have a dewey
well let's look at your options you're a
clown [ __ ]
no one takes you seriously you should be
getting electroshock therapy
[ __ ] if it was a years ago you'd be
rosemary kennedy
you'd have your and i know i know i'm
not making fun of mentally ill but my
mother's a [ __ ] nut and i know
these people are and i know that your
boyfriend donald trump's out of office
now and trust
the plan never happened and you know you
couldn't storm the capitol because
you're too far away from the [ __ ]
house you've never left
um you're you're a joke to everyone so
if you come on my page again
i'm just gonna do this again i'm just
gonna keep reminding the hundreds of
thousands of people that listen to me
some of whom who may know you what an
absolute scumbag you are
and how much of a disgusting pig you
continue to be
for this all this time so keep going at
me
please please